we talked about citizenship education
and the relationship with with human
rights education with democracy also
democracy at school for example this is
cool Parliament and we talked about
teachers empowerment in improving
teachers education and also using best
practices for example websites a couple
of countries make so there's a lot to
learn from each other and we will
continue also during the May Council to
elaborate on the issue of the
radicalization the plan is to adopt this
in time for the next meeting of
education ministers at the end of May we
need to equip Europeans with the right
skills at all levels of education and
anticipate which skills will be needed
in the future the stakes are high twenty
percent of Europeans lack basic skills
reading and counting and forty percent
of them have hardly any or no digital
skills far too many young people drop
out of school early our newest kiss
agenda for europe is to tackle these
challenges Europeans need the right
skills to be employable this include a
broader set of horizontal skills that
education from early childhood to
university should provide we took
forward our first to implement the
commitments we made a year ago in Paris
to promote our fundamental values and
inclusion through education this is a
priority for me as just the minister
mentioned today's meeting was a learning
process when we learned from each other
best practices and and experiences we
heard very inspiring examples from
France the Czech Republic and Spain on
ha on how to help young people use the
internet in a critical way on how to
burst the citizenship education and on
how to empower teachers we plan to focus
on several aspects first on increasing
the level of skills in Europe we want to
help people
achieve at least the equivalent of an
upper secondary squall ification
secondly we want to increase the quality
and the attractiveness of vocational
education and training making it indeed
the first choice and not a second or a
third option and thirdly we must ensure
that qualifications are more easily
comparable among European and even third
countries this is particularly relevant
when it comes to the successful
integration of migrants and asylum
seekers